This episode was proudly
made possible by Subaru.
[HEARTBEAT]
So there's a great
line by Shakespeare
in which he says,
"We know what we are.
We know not what we may be."
And in the age of
accelerating technologies
in which we extend the
cognitive reach of our minds,
the perimeters of our humanness,
with these extensions of self,
these exoskeletons, these
technological scaffoldings--
you know, the wings
of our aircrafts
and the signals traveling
through our smartphones,
sending our
thoughts, electrified
at the speed of light,
across oceans of sky--
we redefine and extend
what it means to be human.
Edward O. Wilson says we
have actually decommissioned
natural selection, and now we
must look deep within ourselves
and decide what
we wish to become.
We are now the chief
agents of evolutions.
We have reverse-engineered
the software of biology
and are about to
rewire and upgrade it,
redefine what it is
to be a Homo sapien.
Juan Enriquez uses the
term Homo evolutis,
the being that evolves itself,
that transforms itself, right?
Ray Kurzweil-- we didn't
stay in the caves.
We haven't stayed on the planet.
Biology-- just another
membrane to be transcended.
You know, Marvin
Minsky used to say,
will robots inherit the Earth?
Yes, they will.
But they will be our children.
You know, I love this idea,
because we hear the term
"transhumanism,"
and what it means
to be human is to be transhuman.
We are the species that
transforms and transcends.
We never stop.
We always did.
It's what we are.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Be sure to check out
Second Chance Subaru
at revision3.com/subaru.